yeah Jackie decided to tie her hair last
night it was like a really emotional
thing for her but she's looking really
good no I'm kidding
Jackie is in Florida as you know and I
was left with like a day's notice to
find a really good co-host and
thankfully Darren Karp was the woman to
do it
I'm so excited she's here if you guys
don't know Darren carb which you
obviously do because she's co-hosted
before right she is she's so many things
she's the co-host of martinis and murder
that's correct which is an oxygen
podcast right that's correct
I'm just so informed and you were also
living the dream as Andy Cohen's
assistant always everybody you're also
the star of that auto trader commercial
yes I am
what's that crazy we're going to talk
about all this we have a lot so I feel
like Jared's more of like a guess than a
co-host like I need her to do both so
this is what we're going to Jim we got
great questions from you guys about
Darren so we're gonna do the Fast Five
gab all about the Royal Wedding and Nev
Schulman etc at the UM then we're gonna
go into like guest mode and treat Darren
like she's under investigation connect
so many questions about like just her
day today like the logistics of it all
like who really decides that housewife
has to leave like I'm just I just have
so many questions so without further ado
I'm going to introduce the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and I have papers and
don't my papers well actually my being
your Beatrice oh and now you own the
pink Jackie's in charge of like the iPad
and like she wouldn't give it to me cuz
I she needed it for the plane so Ike I'm
like back in the Stone Age with my
papers but whatever this is so newsy she
wouldn't give you an iPad because she
wanted it for the plans yet he is
obsessed with her iPad it's like this
whole thing she has to justify the
amount of money that you spent on it so
she has to use it everywhere like she
doesn't use her computer she loses her
iPad okay you guys the Royal Wedding is
so close what are your thoughts on the
Royal Wedding honestly I like don't
really care what oh my god you are gonna
die it's like we are obsessed we've been
reporting on it every day cuz like
something new is happy yeah the drama Oh
with the dad oh I know the dad the
hugging mr.gold yes so now I've been
reported that what's his name uh
Williams and Harry's dad Charles is
gonna walk her down that yes which look
great which will look great it's like a
little sad like that she is like no
family not even enough to walk her down
the aisle what does that say a lot okay
yes I just asking so in Jewish weddings
both the parents walk down the aisle and
I feel like they're so like traditional
like they wouldn't let the mom walk her
down like why the mom has been
behaving so well she deserves that honor
it's 2018 and she's looking to say she's
half black like it's amazing let's start
a trend let's go all in yeah why are you
walking her down the aisle I know that's
my vote
I mean my hat with like the British flag
on it did I come today yesterday and I
was gonna wear it the whole show so like
I'm really upset so I'll just wear it
this whole weekend exactly so our first
story is obviously about the royal
wedding I can't stop talking about it
thinking about it like breathing about
it you watch suits I've watched it
before I haven't I never watched it but
they're all there they're all in London
oh I mean that's their that's their
thing you know what's so crazy it's like
I just love with like celebrities and
like politics like everything connects
so like Patrick Adams is going cuz he
was on the show right and he obviously
got a plus-one because he's married to
Troy in Belisario frumpy little liars
and it's just like a small girl from
Pretty Little Liars is going to the
Royal Wedding do you know I mean I
actually love Pretty Little Liars okay
that show was horrible like it was
really good for like five minutes but
then it got okay that's true well that's
most evening that is true except for
every jumper bra but that's actually
true no that's we're gonna get into it
yeah okay so this is the first story
that about the Royal Wedding so so
there's some major changes happening in
Meghan Marcos life the first is that her
mom Doria had tea with Charles who was
how his dad and his wife Camilla who's
the divorcee it was like all that drama
but now I think they have a lot in
common because what a royalty - Meghan
is it's such a royal thing to do it
high tea like it has Americans but like
yeah yeah we had in and out like that we
drove we took an uber that would be yeah
and beer so Meghan Merkel's mom and
Prince Harry's dad are getting to know
each other out of the Royal Wedding
Daurio Raglan who's Megan's mother
arrived in London on Wednesday carrying
a Burberry garment bag I don't know what
that says very important she flew in
from LA Prince Charles and Camilla
Duchess of Cornwall invited Ragland
that's a terrible last name oh my god I
love the way you said it though
Ragland to their London home Clarence
for tea on Wednesday afternoon people
confirm like have a [ __ ] to speak you
might know like okay how does People
magazine know that for sure
it's an insider source so like who's
that exactly right no it's just like so
fake we're insider sources
oh by the way I'm a big entire I'm gonna
go tell us weekly all about the [ __ ]
that went down right here and it's gonna
be intense I would love for them to
start talking about my dad I've missed
it
no like I can't believe the royal
weddings tomorrow because like I don't
know what I'm going to talk about or
think about like after that hold on are
you waking up at like 4 a.m.
are you like 650
and so turn it on when I was in high
school we'll even cake out a tree and it
was much more like involved in there
when up she was just cause like that's
such a fairy tale like she was born for
this role he didn't have to choose her
he picked her around for like ten years
like totally yeah and they're truly in
love like I don't know if Harry and I
got 48 children like they're just like
they're the perfect story so like I was
really investing that I didn't go to
school that I said I watched all night I
got all those like limited edition
Vanity Fair magazines like I was
obsessed I don't have that sort of like
obsession this time but I like I do
because it's so crazy like I can you
believe just like in this moment what's
happening like I'm happy that he found
his person however we're gonna say but
it did kind of feel like all of a sudden
he was dating magnet Markel and then
they're married right every day I was
like I didn't believe that they were
even dating until the royal wedding
announcement like when they got in range
and they went and walked out in front of
that like green pasture and I talked
about it if you're in front of the green
pasture though you're official you need
a green pasture here I think that was
that sandwich with Julie Montagu I think
that's just what I heard I don't know I
just like I don't know I felt ever
become exhausted about talking about
this because I just can't believe that
no I mean it's gonna be a very it's
gonna be a royal affair how's Megan
Marko ever been on much happens live I
pre not not that I'm aware of and he
could have been invited if he played his
cards right and had her on he would have
died for it you know what would have
been so amazing about Andy going to the
Royal Wedding yeah just the content we
would generate like he would generate
and we would get to consume think of the
Instagram stories so he went to the
Cardinals name last night like a rather
mundane with his parents like nothing
else I think I think put together an
amazing like an amazing array of
Instagram has done premium contain iam
so imagine if he was given the
opportunity to go to the Royal Wedding
like I just I needed that they
specifically made sure he wasn't invited
because it would have been it would have
we order a focused on his Instagram
stories and tuned I would've went to
happy exactly like that
okay let's move on to something like a
majorly dramatic that I actually broke
on the morning shows Instagram stories
yesterday Nev Schulman denies misconduct
on the set of catfish after an accuser
details allegations so it's a little
confusing waits written BK like muddy
yeah let me explain so this is a YouTube
video was released about this girl who
said that she was on an episode of
catfish and she did a YouTube video like
behind the scene
this is what really happened and she
claims she never says Neve that's the
thing she names
she says the main guy the main guy she
titles him Jack she never says if his
name is Nev but I think if he were to
ask who the main guy and therefore I'm
Netflix catfish is we would say Nev but
we don't know so she goes quote I have
this guy over here I'm making me three
times as uncomfortable as I already a.m.
he just keeps asking me are you a
lesbian are you bisexual I was like I'm
a lesbian for the 15 50th [ __ ] time
she also added that Jack did not believe
she was a lesbian added to quote take
her out a hundred times repeatedly
called her pretty and after about hotel
recommendations then Nev Schulman
responded yesterday and said the
behavior described in this video did not
happen and I'm fortunate that there are
a number of former colleagues who were
present during this time period and are
willing to speak the truth so he
basically says these claims are false
quote I've been transparent about my
life and would always take
responsibility for my actions
and this is where everything gets muddy
for me cuz like I always like out here
offending people and I really don't mean
to like I'm really just trying to like
be funny but I'm never one to victim
lame or like the second guess a victim
because if that's her experience then
that's what happened agreed but I'm also
I have a hard time like just assuming
someone's an a sexual alligator and
smearing their name because someone says
so there's a fine line because then Greg
would just go out on the street and
accuse someone right yeah
so as a lesbian yourself yes do you have
any thoughts I'm like someone just like
constantly hounding you about your
sexuality it happens all the time with
men actually they'll be like I don't
really believe that you're a lesbian
it's impossible I'm like okay well I'm
not here to prove a direct yeah like I'm
cool with it
it doesn't really I mean I wouldn't
consider that sexual harassment it's
just annoying yeah but do you think
that's like an that's an isolated
incident for lesbians or that happens to
like gay men too I think it probably
happens more for lesbians yeah because
the sexual nature I think the and
especially believe that like they
wouldn't want to be like how could you
not want this and I'm like exactly okay
well he claims he didn't do it but then
now like you know when someone said
something about you like there's a
hundred other like people come out and
say like the same thing happened to me
weren't you right exactly right so there
hasn't been anything like that but
people are citing an excerpt from his
book basically and it's awkward because
like he admitted it's not
this was a secret like he wrote about in
his book yes look so he wrote about the
time he was tossed out of a Sarah
Lawrence College for punching a girl in
the face in the passage he explains his
behavior by saying he hadn't been aware
of the fact that the person he punched
was a woman she was short quote that's
what they said short stocky and crew-cut
styled well like that's offensive
also why are you punching anyone in at
Sarah Lawrence what are you thinking
what are the odds that it's not a woman
no but like nothing bad goes on at Sarah
Lawrence oh wait what are the odds it's
an all-girls College exactly why are you
there not only why are you there and why
are you assuming that the person you're
punching is not a woman no totally
you're wrong you think he's always
giving me weird vibes cause like you
know what's underrated about catfish is
that the whole kind of experiment
started because he was catfished so
right he's all cool now but like lets me
not forget like he was in his basement
like talking to people on the internet
like falling in love with them you know
what I mean he probably that's not a bad
thing but like no and you know my
kleezak sorry about Nev Schulman is yeah
tell me I married in the Hamptons over
the summer okay
and the night of his wedding were you
there yes no I saw him after his wedding
like on the beach him and his wife and a
couple friends like went out to a club
like rush Myers and I was walking in and
like he was being such a dick he was you
don't know who I am I wouldn't let him
in even though his wife was like
literally standing there in a wedding
dress it was like really odd I think
that's the saddest thing when people say
that like that's like standing in line
at clubs because I am it's like Oh
sweetie
no oh my god that it's the worst thing
you could possibly the most embarrassing
thing for me hands down I'm not gonna
lie I've gotten really drunk and I
haven't done worse you know you haven't
done that I swear on my life but I was
in like a hotel in Boca and like it was
like honestly like a lit hotel and like
everyone was straight I didn't know you
were Jewish I know you know he's telling
Boca I'm like yep
okay it was New Year's and they were
having like a big party and like it was
like 4:00 in the morning like the night
was over and they were you know they get
about those like blowy things like for
New Year's like yeah yeah so I wasn't
meeting so annoying like blowing it's
still out of these people at the table
next we were like Boca trash I mean
we're like can you stop and I literally
was like I was like do you know how many
Instagram followers Bob I thought he was
like you have to go upstairs I literally
was about to get into a screaming fight
Jackie
immediately
goes to her iPad warning the [ __ ] out of
her sister so I've never done that and I
was like a real learning lesson for me I
was like I do not want to be that person
no but like I'm not gonna lie and say
I've never done anything like it that's
why you're owning your [ __ ] here yeah
yeah yeah but I love seeing people do
that I love seeing cool people not got
into clubs I want yeah I like it from
afar oh very close up yeah I don't want
to know you but I want to watch the
whole thing like really close like when
Lamar Odom's didn't get into that Club
because Khloe was inside and they had to
turn him away or when like Paul
McCartney couldn't get into that Grammy
party at the end and I was like it's
amazing like or when all those underage
kids couldn't get into me on carnival at
Coachella cuz they were like really
strict about IDs like Kendall Jenner and
Justin Bieber like couldn't get in it's
the best thing I've ever heard it's so
relatable cuz like I've not gotten into
places like so many times oh well
you're a child well yes but even not as
a child right it's super embarrassing
and you can get into my club any time
you bet it is so nice but you need to
prove your Instagram followers okay I
don't think there's anything more
embarrassing and like more grounding
than not getting into a club well
waiting online to get into a club is
embarrassing in itself and then saying
like you know what yeah what a minutes
later once you get into the front thank
you
horrifying yeah so now I just don't
leave my house to avoid embarrassment
Thank You me too I go to bed at 9:00 me
too right
except last night what's beds so late
I'm like I'm really feeling it how late
is late well for me it's like twelve I
prefer like 10:30 11:00 oh wow
I'd like to hear do you hear that I
heard yeah I got it
you really need to like vacation in Boca
every single I do yeah except sing if
like you're like kind of her in Boca for
me
alright peace I gave liquor yeah yeah
well actually um I was like really on
her side like until like she was
indefensible that whole Margaret and
thing you were on her side
originally which is the thing okay I was
totally I'm singing sad because she came
on a show first and was so unbelievably
cool she's the nicest human ever turtle
and I just she was a come to my house
for spot I just loved her
yeah I'm Jackee like we're obsessed with
it we're like one to be her kids then
dental trauma started happen but I was
like iced and Margaret sorry like I'm I
mean it sorry Ziggy yeah standby key and
I was like I hate Margaret and then
Margaret came on the show and couldn't
have been more lovely she's another less
you the nicest human being ever and I
was like well why do I do now and then I
eventually just completely soldered with
Margaret because like everyone else was
and I love my grimoire
and she had a better position for it I'd
like to choose right yes it was correct
okay anyway we like silent we will
somehow be able to make a tangent off of
any of these stories and always bring it
back to Bravo which is kind of amazing
that you know what that's a feel like
such a true staying power of you guys
but also brought you know it has
literally nothing to do with us and just
only to do with Bravo
are you excited at Project Runway's
coming back to Bravo it's so because I
still watch them live time and like I
just I I hated saying him and I watched
a show on lifetime do you know what I
mean I watched unreal I have been
meaning to watch on Rio actually wait
isn't I know that's TV land
that's what younger son Tipu and
Yeager's on TV land's so can be a great
show that's a great show but like a TV
lines really yeah but okay
did you see American woman is like
premiering like tonight I know go Kyle
Richards rather a good fern for getting
on paramount network cuz that's like a
cool Network now that it's rebranded
from Spike Kyle Richards is cool [ __ ]
cool
no I'm a summer yeah she's cool okay
story number three I'm gonna be honest I
truly couldn't care less offset is
hospitalized after a car wreck offset
whose Cardenas fiance and a member of me
goes yeah totally destroyed his muscle
car and got a little banged up himself
in the process TMZ has learned the migos
rapper wrecked his green Dodge
Challenger
well you're asking for that car to be
racked in Atlanta late Wednesday night
had to be taken to the hospital after
word from minor injuries according to
our sources connected to offset we're
told he's already been released and is
expected to be ok his car not so much I
have like no sympathy for offset really
sure what he did to card eBay cheating
on her
nobody cheats on car TV I mean cardi B
is like the Queen when it's cardi B
gonna be on watch outside because that
will be would kill for it
oh yeah like DM her right now and tell
her to get it one drive that would be
the best half an hour of television it
would be the best happen it would have
to be in our can do I have no idea like
what she's saying and that's what would
make it so great yeah it would be like
our on the level of like the
extravaganza like very close because
hearing cardi B talk about it and then
and II say like Mazal back yeah that's
like a cultural melting pot but the
extravagance it was so epic because
she's obsessed with Bravo she's a super
fan knows everything so like that was
like it's almost like frustrating for of
course I'm somehow talking about watch
happens live but it's so much
frustrating when guests aren't in tune
with like what's going on on Bravo was
just
right no and it's like I love when like
Lea Michele she's like a huge problem
for Lawrence it's like the biggest
Vanderpump it's so epic to get to see
like housewives I need to get to see
real celebrities like on watch outside
like drinking being cool live no filter
but then when did they also happen to
watch Bravo it's so incredibly like
they're amazing for you just like us
yeah yes they are just like us like
Chrissy Teigen a true Bravo and also the
funniest human being and she's like
keeping dinner from not that benefi bros
would be dead without her but like she's
like keeping the ratings up I gotta say
Vanderpump rules was the best show on
television though I completely agree
like hands down deserved an Emmy no I'm
not even not even less is my question
why don't reality TV shows get Emmys
because they're better than real shows I
agree it's a modern a soap opera
if days of our lives I said we agree it
can win Daytime Emmys I understand why
we can't win an Emmy and there's an
element of like acting to it to some of
these shows I think there's an element
of like vulnerability you're writing up
your whole life to it I definitely think
you know how to play the camera once
you're like season two three four I
completely agree but there's a stigma
with reality TV I do and you know what
I'm distinguishing it like
single-handedly thank you you're doing
God's work no I really am like when
people ask me what shows i watch they're
like I'm like I'm from Brule's house my
eyes well Jack and I know like what like
real shows like no no those are real
shows like they're like 60 minutes
they're like 60 minutes no I'm like 15
minutes of real house yeah I'm like no I
want to be beep I mean Phoebe's awesome
Julia Louie Dreyfus is my everything
I would give my whole I would give my
left leg to be with her um same actually
I would more still get my left leg to be
with Selina Meyer her character well
yeah okay over like Elaine Benes because
I think that's fair but like jail d jail
do disabilities epic and she's I love
how like brave she's being through her
battle with breast cancer and how she's
sharing like a decent amount of it on
social media because she's really not
that like public of a person know it's
an important message I really like it
she's clean she could do something
terrible and I'd be like it's important
that she's doing it right I just be like
if she's really having a strong message
hahaha
doesn't matter what the message is I'm
like you go girl good for you yeah okay
story number four I'm breezing through
these stories because I just like I need
to dedicate like half the job which is
just talking to Darren and also another
story I truly cannot care less about Mac
Miller is arrested on DUI and
hit-and-run charges after ariana grande
split he's not taking it you really
don't care about like driving axe
you like that's a shame unless it's like
a Paul Walker like he was okay travesty
like he died basically I like it had a
DUI like get your life together I don't
wanna talk about you on my prestigious
Morning Joe yeah and I don't understand
these people who have like three duis
right like learn the first time at the
firt I'm like it but it's not that's
like okay you could kill yourself but
like you kill other people I don't care
like you're gonna be reckless with
yourself cool don't take it out on me
and my fellow civilian correct thank you
do it like Bella Hadid when when you
launder was I'm out for Everly Hills she
got a DUI and she learned about saying
she never got it again exactly oh so
you're rich just go get a driver get
right get her driver : uber by that I no
one is allowed to have to you guys
anymore ever since uber was a thing like
not no excuse and hopefully with
self-driving cars they'll be eradicated
that's true I don't think I would trust
the self-driving car yes but I mean like
okay but better than a car accidents
happen all the time on the road that's
true that's true
but like at least keep someone to blame
when there's a car well that's true yeah
robot yeah okay so here are the details
if you should give a shred of a shed
Mac Miller was arrested on DUI and
hit-and-run charges in the early hours
of Thursday May 17th Us Weekly confirms
LAPD officer Rosario Herrera thank you
for your service tells us that the dang
rapper 26 I didn't know he'd a song
called Bing hit a utility pole with his
mercedes-benz g-wagen oh such a nice car
at 1:00 a.m. and knocked it down
Oh with a wagon oh my god there were two
passengers and they fled the scene and
him and two passengers so three people
total not cool fled the scene on foot
the officers ran the license plate on
his SUV and then found his address they
went to his house where he said he
confessed to drunk driving and fleeing
the scene he was taken to a local jail
really shortly before 9:30 a.m. his bail
has been set at $15,000 fleeing the
scene is usually not a good no that's
like the most fucked-up thing you could
do but I think a lawyer would tell you
to flee the scene if you're drunk
and like this is [ __ ] out but this
little wire says because then they can't
prove that you were drunk driving cuz
you could have went to a bar afterwards
you don't I mean oh they are they don't
know your alcohol level they can't test
right or like they don't find you till
morning in your sober me why do you have
so much knowledge about this okay it's
really [ __ ] up you want to know why
because I was really invested in the
Chris what's it sold you know Chris also
after this he killed someone
drunk driving he yeah and like he it was
really like like both
go uni or others I probably didn't the
toast dedicated like their entire lives
but it was really it was [ __ ] up so
basically he left the scene also I'm
assuming at the advice of his lawyer and
they don't know if he was drunk because
they didn't find him till the next day
but he had beer in his car so awesome
he hit yeah he rear-ended like someone
in the tractor-trailer because he lives
in Iowa and this lovely farm men died
Kenneth Moshe it's like a really sad
story so now I know everything about
like duis itself oh my god and how can
you go on I mean you the torture you
must feel after that has to be
horrendous right because like he's not a
bad guy I'm like bringing down the
morning this morning my look I do
martinis and murder so I wait fascinated
right oh are you Wow what's the craziest
like murder you've investigated on the
show well I mean the one that was the
first one we did was the gold and say
killer that you stare a rapist and they
just called him by doing like a fake
genetic profile after he was a serial
rapist and murderer from the 70s and 80s
and had raped and murdered like 50
people and he was like in a retired cop
like the whole thing was like crazy and
it was like one of the most prolific
things that they never solved year and a
half later they saw fit
I stolen questions for you we have
different Stasi on that podcast no but
you should I love her and I'm and she's
obsessed with like murder you talk about
it all the time
you Chevron I would love to have her on
and if she comes on teller was my idea
well I can only give credit to you
everything I've gift card to you I think
wait number two I had a question oh who
do you think killed Gemini oh if you
want my I mean I think the brother had
something to do with it here's the thing
about that is that I can't say
definitively so I'm not gonna call
someone like a murderer be out here
smearing someone before noon let me say
this if it was the brother hmm I
understand the parents wanting to
protect the son because then you lose
both of our children so I understand
that aspect of it do you think oj did it
of course of course okay babe what do
you think he's he Anthony did it I just
covered this on my pocket did you like
can't talk about like what our personal
opinions are there's like a huge lawsuit
going on oh is it and I am my girlfriend
called me last night and we went through
every single scenario I'm she goes goes
I think you're overthinking this and
this is what I think happened and I was
like no there's there's so many
different factors no one everyone about
it everyone lied that whole that whole
child that whole trial and lying does
not improve intent do you see Anthony
yes it
okay she does he no wonder why she
doesn't even seem upset that her
daughter's dad do you know any mean well
I mean all these time fear so pang who
asked for in and out in the cop car on
the way to go after he found at Laci
Peterson died there but at the same time
it's in and out well that's true right I
would be more so like can we go to like
Chumley palace because I want my chicken
broccoli yeah each is own see that's a
person trying to say okay what was the
first murder you said I didn't I never
heard of it East area rapist Golden
State killer
Golden State killer yeah definitely look
it up you should do that podcast filmed
because I feel like it's like so
visually like you need like a Forensic
Files like type of yeah I mean and you
can see it's getting like sloppy drug
talking about rapes and murders and who
is almost John Thrasher and you guys
bartend a lot right we bartend a lot
we're gonna come on I think in June and
watch what happens live he's great very
nice a man very excited very exciting
okay so an actor drunk I'm Mac Miller
somehow ended up I watch something as I
expected yes
so he's fired he's out of jail I wonder
what Ariana Grande's thinking and if she
feels responsible I don't know
ariana grande's on the cover of Time
magazine like like an activist to the
future and she talks a lot about
Manchester which like Manchester it was
like something that really stuck with me
like I literally couldn't something me
about it and like I Candice imagine like
being in that position you know name Ian
well this is like a V Schumer after
exact like all this gills even though
it's not your fault no of course not but
those people technically were there for
her you're paying to go see this product
right and they say first Amy she was
like never born that person wouldn't
have went to go see Trainor do you know
any mean no absolutely and I'm not
blaming her obviously but like I can
understand anything Amy shoe okay I can
understand like her being in that
mindset and like how difficult it is and
now I know why she's like so proactive
about like gun violence in kind reform
thank God though she's actually taking
like the proper stand and like she is
such an easy way to do it because her
uncle is Chuck Schumer exactly that is
like I love fighting out people are
related you love politics and pop
culture I just love to make things
intertwine yeah and like okay have you
seen oh I have you seen the Netflix
movie the kissing booth no okay
it came out like a week ago oh I need
you to watch it what's I don't think
you'll like it
but you need it's what you want to waste
my time watching it okay so it's like a
Disney buy movie like high school
romance okay but it's like a little bit
edgier like they curse and they like
talk about how high school are is like
have Saxon my drink i'm like it's
realistic thank god
yeah and that's what i really like to
have movie like the realist
sickness of it all like Disney like they
don't like they don't talk about
anything like kids like they drink it
like this went pot and they have sex at
night school I'm like we should talk
about it that's what makes me so that's
why I like the movie but oh so the main
actress is Joey King do you know who
that is no she's like not really famous
I'm not surprised that you don't know
where and I think her sisters Jamie King
okay Jamie I know Jamie King but then
someone told me she's not her sister and
I'm like but I checked last night and I
think she is like would she get juji
have to wait in line for 20 minutes to
get into like it on yes she's not nearly
that famous at it but just watch her
movie I would love to know what your
thoughts on it because you're like
actually like smart and like
well-rounded I'm like thanks I'm like a
[ __ ] like the village idiot and I just
think like two-year-old movies are cool
so I would know like a smart person's
perspective I'll come back and give my
like analysis I think I got 500 people
to watch a movie
kissing booth done it's so good done
okay this next story is a perfect segue
into talking just about you in general
great this is like so crazy I can't get
over it because are you all caught up in
roses in New York yes of course do you
watch things live or do watch them TBR
well I work at Bravo so I usually watch
them before they air sorry yeah that's
like the most annoying response alright
they know who I am at Bravo are you able
to get screeners
oh is this is this where you're like
coaxing me to like think I get screeners
for southern charm
sadhana okay but that's it and I've
tried to get fur Beverly Hills in
housewives in New York but like they
haven't had too much more like secure PR
team then then like the newer show
correct I also got what's the might have
gotten below Jack oh it did get below
deck but how does one go about getting
screeners just curious honestly for me I
mean they just give me access on a thing
because I have to watch them for my web
series that I do I know I see like your
face like getting angered at me right I
see it like annoying I I feel the anger
in this room I just want you guys all to
know I would say you know just handout
20-dollar bills where I offer you know
all those girls I do I love them she'll
teach oh yeah do you know what she'll
teach yeah are you kidding you love
Michelle cheese I am obsessed with her
and she told me she's like oh used to do
stand-up comedy and I was like no so
when my I did my first show at
Caroline's like I was so nervous and she
was like telling me she did stand-up I'm
like you just stand up and she was like
so helpful and supportive
a la Erika Jayne helping to read before
her performance that's exactly what she
did and she's the funniest most lovely
um actually
okay Carol rads well released a blog
which by the way I think the blog format
is really amazing on Bravo and they
likely you haven't gotten rid of it
you'd think it'd be passe right the hell
cares about this because Instagram life
no blogs are so important though and all
the ladies are really smart and eloquent
especially Carol she's a writer girl
right so I think that like the whole
concept of blogs is amazing and the fact
that they haven't become obsolete I'm
really grateful for oh I will let them
know
and Harold got majorly sassy in her blog
too happening ready cow rads well has
had enough the rahani star took to her
Bravo blog to address events that were
depicted by the Wednesday May 16th
episode of the reality series
specifically statements made by her
co-star Bethenny Frankel the two
co-stars became friends off screen and
spending time together when cameras
weren't rolling when the season 10
trailer dropped included scenes alluding
to some kind of friendship fracture
between the two as the season progressed
the comments made in the show and in
interviews the two made comments are now
in her blog Carol goes all in are you
ready this is I want you all saying how
you think that she meant it that's what
I want
happily a dramatic reading of Carol
Brad's well yes this is gonna get your
Emmy I'm glad ok this is her words not
mine I swear I love you Bethany
I'm glad to see my friend Bethany step
outside of her affluent bubble with her
stream of a rich boyfriend's rich
friends with private planes million
dollar homes and five-star resort
vacations one gets the impression that
this is the first time she's witnessed
real poverty it can be life-changing I
know it was for me many years ago when I
first covered tragedies as a journalist
the shock of having then losing one's
home and all its possessions and having
the guts and dignity to soldier on it's
awe-inspiring
it is partly why I quietly give money to
charities and political campaigns I
believe will make a difference in the
world and why years ago I created my own
charitable fund like there's lots
there's lots to unpack ok let's start at
the very beginning first stuff is about
charity right like people are like we
were kind of discussing Bethany actually
did an amazing job an incredible job I
was paying attention when no one else
was the fact that anyone could have
something negative to say about this
whole thing it's like really upsetting
whatever you think about Bethany she
charter her own private plane to go give
them relief it's unbelievable like she
was responsible for millions and
millions of dollars donated she
responsible rich person she's premium
content but ok
it's really bothering me that like it'd
be one thing this might be true if
Metheny was born with like a silver
spoon in her mouth and like never had to
work for anything but like as you see
and do in Beth of real houses in New
York like she worked so hard to become
rich and like that's my favorite type of
story it's like a success story the
American dream
you see her in like Gristedes like
hawking her [ __ ] right like when no one
games
no one gets a crap about her not being
that little skinny girl car and she had
a rough family life growing up like she
kind of talks about that for the news
yeah use her father everything going on
there like she did not have it easy
no like she really took Real Housewives
of New York and made it something for
herself so what Jackie and I always say
brief tangent is that there's two kind
of routes that you can take as a Real
Housewives yeah
the Kim Zolciak Bethany round whoa okay
are we doing Kim Zolciak in Bethany I'll
tell you why that's my rap okay more
like the Alexis later right yeah that's
another route yes so like Kim Zolciak
before BBH before housewives yeah was
had two kids by two different men living
in a townhouse didn't really have a job
was ready to a marry dating a married
man had a break clap Oh resent his
lesbian yeah and then who doesn't them
blame a girl and then all of a sudden
like her life completely turned around
yes and yes it has a lot to do with
house it has a lot to do with Kroy also
like he made her I actually love that
relationship universe him like oh we'll
get into that in a minute okay who do I
talk to about about making dough be
tardy an hour instead of 30 minutes it's
the best show on Bravo
it's the only show on Bravo I can get my
girlfriend to watch is it same with Ben
it's his favorite job yeah
favorite job is it true that they paused
production there were rumors that they
did I plead the fifth
Oh production they did they did it sit
back honor it's so pause I think it's
back on okay I think drama I think okay
we'll talk about Oh in the middle in a
minute yes so like and then Bethenny
like obviously skinny girls a great
product I don't think it would have been
bought for nearly as much of it didn't
have all the press of course at
housewives gave it she turned it and she
turned it around which is aggressive
yeah so like for anyone to say that like
she's super affluent and only knows rich
boyfriends rich plains privately like
that's an obnoxious and incorrect
Jason Hoppy wasn't anything oh he's what
she had to deal with with that sociopath
you should have him as a case study on
martinis and murder
oh my honestly I don't even want to be
in five feet from him me neither
everything she discussed on the roadie
reunion last year was like tragic
showing up to the school like I feel bad
for Bryn it's really sad like do
whatever you want to Bethany but you
have a child yeah and I honestly don't
do whatever you want to Bethany cuz he's
been doing that for like five years but
like at least she's an adult you know
what I mean like she can have a Racine
Your Honor that coming down to Bryn has
got to be so traumatic awful and you
know what's so funny bravo did I'm like
a marathon of reunions for real houses
in New York like a week ago
and it was so funny with every reunion
and he asked Stephanie like how's the
divorce she's like we're at the end like
we're finally at the end and like a year
later so yes we're finally we're getting
there like 10 years later he's finally
ended finally I'm really happy for her I
know me too she deserved that I know I
just think this is super hurtful like
and then she's like well in her defense
Bethenny did say like that Kyle didn't
really show an interest and be strong
and didn't really donate money right Joe
Carroll's out here defending herself
like actually I quietly have my own
charitable fund I quietly give money to
different organizations so I understand
in her blog her wanting to like just
state the facts prove herself here but
this first passage is incredibly
condescending well it's like she's never
seen poverty right I have my own chair
it's like a backhanded or really a front
handed like compliment what upper
situation upper situation Marin LuAnn
was the one-upper in like season one
real hustle a boy like Luann's
like epic she is an amazing one upper
and I think I sat on her for a while
like I wasn't I wasn't understanding her
but mostly I went to her cabaret show
and like and you gotta set everything
then you got it it all made sense you
absorbed who the countess was and now it
really makes sense for you exactly okay
good okay so like what I'm sure you
can't tell us but I'm sure you've
probably seen already what happens cuz
like you're just fortunately you're not
bitter at all about this privilege yeah
I mean I don't have to wait in line how
do you what what happens with Carol
Bethenny just it was like a brief
overview I mean I think you're gonna see
the relationship unfold in a different
way than you've never seen it before a
lot of like teacher jargon this season
is of Real Housewives of New York is my
favorite season so far I don't know the
end I haven't seen all of them were
still like cuz they go to Carter Pena
and they
like dye in the boat they go to Colombia
and before they even went to Colombia
cuz I saw Bethany two weeks before she
even left for the Colombia trip because
I was filming something with her I was
like what were you guys going the season
she's like we're in Colombia I was like
this is gonna knock it and well no
matter what like you're going to
Colombia it is not anything well no
they're so obnoxious like in like with
their demands for like accommodations
who is in charge now
by the way Fast Five is over now we can
have sarin questions I'm watching on
Facebook so if you guys have questions
for Darren please get them to me and I
will get them to her but I had my own
slew of questions first who plans like
all the accommodations for like Bravo
trips the production company that does
it okay yes and every show is different
reduction of every show is completely
different so I'm overlap with different
things but every product every housewife
is different yeah and what it's like the
budget for like a trip like that for
like let's say when they went to Mexico
which was the most amazing trip I
couldn't even tell you because it
depends on how many seasons there are
where they're going what kind of
accommodations like a season one trip is
going to be completely different than a
season right that's why we're like in
Real Housewives of Dallas went to Austin
and they stayed at Stephanie's house
yeah I mean very little Jeff yeah but
like the Jackson show you know they
weren't on a boat right right to rob
boats and Bravo do not go out together
that's the big joke that we always say
also below deck and below deck Med so
can I tell you that like when below deck
came out I was like okay and he's lost
it I'm like everything I brought was
amazing and like a that wasn't under his
jurisdiction oh it wasn't no we'll see
him at Vanderpump rules like who gives a
[ __ ] about some waiters you know any me
like right in the beginning
totally I understood the scheana
connection okay and the Lisa connection
which we'll talk about this in a minute
yeah but I was like oh they're losing it
waitresses and like yachties I'm like so
silly I'm like I couldn't have been more
wrong I mean how long did it take you to
like really love Vanderpump rules
two minutes below deck took me like a
little bit longer it takes a little bit
and Season one wasn't amazing with like
a me and Kate and then that other two
who was such a [ __ ] cat they were so
mean to Amy they were they were what do
you think of captain sandy and Hannah
okay so I love love-love-love a female
captain me she's a little soft I love I
want a date every single the EP of I
don't know I don't if I should be
married she probably would
I catch like that just gets taken up
this oh my god I would love I would love
it just to be like I date a [ __ ]
yacht yeah no she's epic I like I didn't
captain Lee's like a little too strict
sometimes but yeah captain Sandy's like
a little like like no vibes but she's
getting she's like setting precedent
this season Hannah is everything she and
like she had a tough job to follow cuz
like Kate is like everything cap Chiefs
do like they'll never be another one
like her and I'm like who are they gonna
bring in for med and it was great no
she's perfect and you like knows how to
like yeah I play the game you know what
I mean oh this was a good question
because Jackie ever thought the other
day yeah that they do but just Bravo get
any sort of cut from like housewife
generated businesses that they promote
on the show like I don't think so like
all they're like Skinnygirl or anything
like that know that you like those
toasted Arvind which means right really
gotten a lot of revenue right doesn't
that I should have write that in my blog
yeah no I don't think we got a cut I
think it's you know it's beneficial yeah
for everyone because the more you know
Bethany from her brand then we're gonna
watch our show that's true yeah okay so
what is your like day-to-day because you
are you do a bunch of like digital
content for Bravo yes you have the
oxygen podcast yes you're also full-time
assistant she looks up jobs I'm like
chief of staff of our production company
is what he calls me or like integer but
it's easier just say assistant so like
do you what am i getting is laundry
signs or checks who signs my checks rabo
most talkative or endo an LLC Sony signs
my checks because they run the
production company we chose watch what
happens live zero embassy row very smart
and and then Bravo also signs my checks
so I get how you can that money in that
ring okay so you're not like day-to-day
assistant like you're not getting dry
cleaning I've never gotten his dry
cleaning is there someone else who do
that or he gets it himself I think he
gets it himself or gets a delivered oh I
get it sliver to okay a lot so let you
call it what do you think your Andy good
but so and what are the shows that you
do for Bravo you do podcasts Frank much
which is more popular murder yes it's
wildly popular with a weekly pregame on
Bravo
which is coming back in June what is
that it's like a every Sunday we come
out with like two minutes it's a preview
of everything that you need to watch
that week and then I do it's cool
of interviews with everyone who comes on
watch what happens live to give me the
gossip like oh that's good last season I
was interviewing James Kennedy Lisa
Vanderpump called like in the middle of
my interview and like put it on Mike and
I was like really good I did I liked the
name the Bravo weekly pregame thank you
okay what else and I also do throwback
Bravo which is coming back in the snow
I'm doing seven episodes are epic like
when you do bet in this day in Bravo
history ah this day in housewives
history when I'm like sitting there like
masterpiece I like learn to like do an
ascot my producer bill to set we filmed
all those in like a day just like mess
and roser we wrote those and just did a
profile it's important like educational
knowledge no I think it's good to like
on you know I don't like on Facebook and
be like on this day and then you can
look at yourself being something from
college that's what we wanted to do for
housewives you you want to go back to
Herman Munster shoes and like really
downstairs in your shoes what is Alex
McChord up to when you guys had her on
Marshalls in Australia that was
interesting psychologists I was
incredibly epic and full circle last
time I was on when I was on the morning
breath with Jackie you were in Australia
did you see Alex in the court I wasn't
in Australia why did nobody you were in
Australia I was probably she's not a
flake to her I was like oh really that
must be [ __ ] that's so beard well
I've never been to Australia what and
when you said that before you were like
last I was here you were like in
Australia or something I think about
like a joke like you were just like far
away well someone so clearly I'm not
important enough Jackie you're probably
dying your hair and pissed no I was
probably like seriously like home wait
what did Jackie dye her hair like well
she didn't I was joking cuz you guys
have a same haircut Oh anyway I kind of
look like her now cuz like you guys have
dark hair oh okay wait more questions
everyone keep going how did you first
like get involved with like Bravo Andy
etc very random I was an NBC page like
Kenneth from 30 laughs got so I like
wore suit gave tours of and you see yeah
do you like that job love oh yeah job my
favorite game show of all time was an
NBC page so that's why I wanted to do it
did if we eaten half months and the job
came out to me an assistant to Andrew
Cohen who was the head of development of
production this is before he was like an
on-air personality he was on watch
happens live like one night a week like
people knew who he was but no one really
knew the title like I remember saying to
myself watch it up inside watch outside
because it did wall off the tongue that
wasn't like menno Joe right and my page
bosses were like you absolutely have to
do this your personality which I were so
work well and I was like
don't want to be an assistant don't
watch Bravo don't care
they were like pushing through push me
through push me through right I was like
fine for interviews later I got it i sat
with Andy for a minute and a half and
he's like what's your favorite show
which at least a browser why and I was
like and I was a chameleon or matchmaker
I love because it teaches me what to do
on dates with women yeah
r.i.p Patti Stanger I liked inside the
actor studio probably the only person to
ever say that your look of judgment
right now I'm moving right through it
every time I wear it like a turtleneck I
say I'm like inside that kissy yeah was
like I'm surprised you didn't have like
a big stack of blue cards that you just
flip over and this is easy like I
wouldn't die to talk to him and then he
was like what's your least favorite rose
like all the Housewives and he looked
mortified like just like I can't believe
it's his legs where you're insulting my
bread and butter like what made me
famous and I I was like yeah I just like
don't really relate to the women side no
love the housewives have total respect
for them obsessed with them now it's
like yeah I just like don't really like
it doesn't really I don't relate to them
I left that interview being like no way
no way this [ __ ] job week later he's
like I'm taking you because you're
really honest and like I get you I was
great and then he became like a
superstar the next two years
legitimately like I hit it right at the
right time good for you thank you
has it been like school for you to like
literally watch someone become like
super famous yeah because he's doing but
the thing about him is like he's
actually a hard worker and he has 28
million jobs was a book in print his
radio show he's really three books like
he has a five night a week late night
show like the guy is a [ __ ] Amazon
and I want to talk about the books
because I read all them just because I
think it's super interesting like so
many things I love I just love to see
like inside me I did okay what it's like
to be like really famous and cool like I
just I love the celebrity like and he's
like and he's like us like and you know
what's so interesting is a fan he named
celebrities if he's like someone was
mean to me he'll say the name yeah when
it comes to Bravo people he doesn't name
accounts toys he's like I was on the
phone with a house husband who was
begging me to take his wife back and he
wouldn't say who it was I thought I knew
who it was do you know who it is
I do know who it is I thought it was she
he said was OC okay I think it was
Alexis Bellino husband but it makes a
lot of sense that it would it makes a
lot of sense that it would be but at the
same time he's their boss right so
believe act is there right and like you
know Bravo's paying his paychecks like
right you do have there is a respect
there you know what I mean I think and
no matter
whether you hate him or you love him he
does have respect for every one of them
because they are opening their lives and
so another thing I love about the book
is getting to see he really does like he
literally works all the time like it
makes me tired to read the books
constant and the Diaries the last two
are just like this is what I did today
and it's like welcome to exam to the
radio show yeah had a meeting hosted
this hos this one tomorrow before I've
got know yeah like so lengthy I read it
and I like control ask like my name and
I was like okay here's where I'm gonna
repay ready yeah I read it and when I
bar attended I went to the the day in
the book and like it was April 27th and
I'm like write anything I mean like
obviously he did for like my day was in
the books like whatever and then the
third thing is like you're in the book a
lot I am in the book there's a lot of
personal stuff about like a girl you
were dating yes he had to call me and
ask my permission because it's the only
time I've ever cried at work right can
you tell the story it's like a really
like it struck me and it was like really
sad and made me really upset and then I
was thinking like well this isn't like
fiction like this happened to someone no
it was like it was shin is the real one
fiction is fake so my gay this is not
fiction yes real and like what was it
like for you have you heard from that
girl now that she's like been in a book
never again what's the story so you were
dating a girl and her parents I was
leading a girl for about four or five
months it was like just at the point we
were like falling in love or whatever we
were set up and she was from Alabama and
so you know I knew kind of this this
background story I've been out I've been
whatever forever and she's like okay I'm
going home like for Christmas to come
out because I'm in love with you and I
want to be with you and like this is it
and she I was in her bed that morning
and she like kissed me goodbye and I
went to work that was the last I ever
saw her because at the end I was giving
out our staff gifts which is the watch
happens life jackets that you love those
adidas jacket was I've got one okay
ana dich I was giving them out and I get
a call from her and I pick up the phone
I was like hey babe I'm all excited like
yeah there you go yeah and I was like ah
miss you and it was her mom and she was
like is this Darren and I was like oh
yeah and I thought like her mom or like
really wanted to like get to know like
that's that's how like serious but like
that's how naive and like Jen like
gentle I really was because my parents
are so sweet I was like hey I so nice to
meet you and she just like I don't I
don't even want to say it on air cuz
it's like actually tragic what she said
she would just be like you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I got a shotgun I'm gonna come to New
York I'm gonna jam it down your throat
and I'm gonna blow your [ __ ] head oh
we're and I was in the hallway like at
first off I met literally the gayest
place in the world like I met gay met
though with like all the drag queens
behind me and I'm being like blowing my
friend I didn't even know what to do I
was just like and I just kept saying yes
ma'am
and of course the first thing I say is I
think you're under estimating the joy
that I bring to your daughter's life
because like I'm trying to be mature I'm
trying to be like defuse the situation
work I heard her crying in the
background like in hysterics and she was
like I don't want to say her name cuz
like for whatever blanketing it what
color Ashley she was like as she get
over here and tell this [ __ ] that
you're choosing me over her and she gets
on the line and she was like I choose my
mom were you like in hysterics and never
heard from her never heard from again
she called the mom called me back to
again like reiterate that I should be
calling the police because she will blow
my head off
she was like Ashley will tell me where
you live and I will come to your
apartment and kill you
so I had to call the police and like
where is it did so I went yeah I have a
bunch of lawyer friends so I called them
and like had to make sure I went on the
record saying what happened but I was in
such shock I went into Andy's office and
I was like I just put my things down I
was like I need to just cry but like in
reaction to something and I just need
you to like sit here with me for a
second yeah he was like oh my god what
happened to you and he went into full
Papa Bear mode right and just like he
was like I want to write her a letter
yeah I want to like really do something
like it was he bought me a personal
massage afterwards like he was so loving
to me oh my god that is hard it was it
was pretty horrifying like Jay never
hurt herself Miriam never hurt again
that she blocked me out also she
shouldn't say do you like fought like
like sometimes I check back in like just
to see and she was like crying you know
like my Bible Camp like praying the gay
away and I was like yeah she's honestly
like I got to go back to be at watch
what happens live with my super
accepting parents make super accepting
boss and super accepting life I honestly
felt cared for I felt so scared for her
so sad right because she's gay and she
has to live a life that is interesting
torture him yeah and in Alabama that's
the worst part and she wants me an
actress and I just remember thinking hey
what are you gonna move to Hollywood and
hey hey people gay people have fun okay
total tension
yeah is I need to talk about our
container to reunion yeah sorry I'm like
I would like place not to diminish her
crime but let's talk about Erika Jaynes
it was like sweetie was called speaking
of cold and heartless let's talk about
aramid she was weird at this reunion and
she claims she had a migraine and I
actually believed her but what's going
on and there's also a lot of memory
she's not coming back but I haven't good
authority that she has you what's yours
it again side stores so it's like a very
legitimate source that I can't say on
this but I'll tell you after because
everyone came out saying that she was
quitting like she was done every was it
like that was that was it that was what
it was gonna be you know I mean Erika
Jayne is cold I mean her whole opening
line is about being like I don't call
cold I call it diamonds like ice cold I
mean that is her shtick she's kind of I
don't want to say she's shitty to
everyone cuz I'd actually don't view her
as shitty if there is not warm I'm her
number one fan so I love her and she's
been nothing but sweet to me whenever
I've met her interviewed er she has
given me everything and like total sass
no respect I respect her I think like
it's really hard eventually when you
realize not only a first season it's
really easy to open up your life and say
like okay I'm gonna do this but then
when you get a million [ __ ] people
either telling you you're you're fat
you're a piece of [ __ ] write this or
you're that and closed-off it's and
you're more closed off than ever before
and she has a son right and she's super
sensitive about that and so we think for
her it's just better to put up all the
walls and like you have all your cards
away so if she were not to come back
which would be a travesty amongst to
trust his travesties yeah who is the
final say like is it like Andy just
decides and that's interest and a bunch
of people who get to decide that's and
what are the factors like I know where
houses are always talking about their Q
scores yeah just like a statistical
thing like loves me my Q scores 100 or
whatever yeah it mean let's first off
and he's not the only executive producer
it's all a Bravo it's a production
company but I think if none of the women
really want to be around you you're not
gonna be a good show right like it
really is about mingling it's true in
mingling in between like you do want to
have conflict with some of them but you
also want to have your your writer your
dog that ties you back to the group of
course and if no one's really willing to
do that or you don't want to be around
anyone then okay like Phaedra there's
that yeah I mean that was a problem like
no one wanted to be around or no one
trusted her anymore so okay like how can
you have a show around someone who's
completely isolated I am out here
getting justice for Phaedra
because I [ __ ] love her and like yes
what she did was incredibly [ __ ] up
but like yeah people have done worse on
Housewives hundred and I love her and I
think she's everything and I think she's
like an instrumental part of Atlanta she
was very she's always she sends me a
Christmas card every year she's like
legitimately the sweetest person I
totally believe that like I just wanted
to be them like I would like her back
I'm gonna call I'm calling them Bravo
right now thank you yeah you're welcome
thank you so much okay I'm gonna take
some questions for from the audience
because like they're gonna kill me
because I've been asking my own question
okay someone's everyone's talking about
someone named Sean I'm not familiar with
him Jonathan Antin Jonathan Antin yeah
does that levering any bells - not like
a lot a bunch of questions about that
okay never but like in what way oh this
a good question have you Andy gotten
high together yes like all the time I'm
not like all the time but we've gotten
out together multiple times I tell you
sorry yeah I don't smoke pot like at all
that's your first red flag for me no
again it's just like it's just not my
thing okay but been hanging red yeah
left a joint in our apartment
and I was going to watch Evans I've just
been know like six months ago like I was
like watching up inside horror like I
would like use all my contacts see out
there like once a week and I went - oh
no sorry I did the UM when you guys did
social the after show social media yeah
I was the one that I interviewed Andy
for the Instagram that's right and then
it was like a party afterwards and I was
like having the best time and I brought
this joint with me cuz I'm like I read
his book I know he lets people like
smoke him out all the time and I'm like
I'm gonna smoke yeah totally like don't
smoke would you have smoked if Andy was
like do you want to hit this with me so
he did I gave him and I like faked it
and I was like yeah I'm sorry and I was
like this is just so much fun like we're
having such a good time you know like me
my friend Rachel like it was the best
night of my life so you didn't inhale no
I just like put my mouth on it so you
pull a little Bill Clinton you know oh
yeah this is cool you're so cool okay
would you ever bring back oh gee Bravo
shows like blowout or workout I would
love to do that like Tabitha oh yeah
tabatha takes over absolutely I don't
know she's a lesbian she's like
legitimately lesbian we have yeah yeah
came on the breath she's literally the
scariest but like best woman she's
amazing I love her who picks the cases
on martinis and murder how did you get
involved in the podcast great question
pick it our research team picks it
except like you know we're doing Casey
Anthony we have a special coming out on
oxygen about Casey Anthony Hernandez and
martiza murder came about because my
John and I are partners we had our own
podcast we were doing called currently
which was just like [ __ ] around
talking about our jobs just like a way
to like be friends vent and then oxygen
came to us were like we we know that you
have podcast experience we like your
chemistry like would you want to do
something with murder we were like [ __ ]
yeah we would so cool um it's okay so
this is like kind of a hot button button
topic
what's going on with Thomas Ravenel and
it's barbar gonna let him stay on
southern charm I don't know if Robins
gonna let him stay in something southern
charm I actually don't know the answer
to that I'm not even being cheeky T Roth
has a lot of skeletons in his closet
I mean he's older his kids with
Katherine like and he's like Charleston
royalty right he's like his ridges named
after him there's a lot as I don't know
yeah no I wouldn't be surprised if he
doesn't come back a great season though
what is like the method for like new
housewife City it's like when are we
gonna get my army back and when when you
guys gonna do another live reunion do
you want Miami back yeah like hardcore I
think it was do you want to see back no
oh just just Miami
well honestly every time people ask Andy
this he's like we have like seven well
yeah there's and we just got Dallas
we just got Dallas Potomac is starting
to get into the mix as well like Dallas
is really picking up else is so good
because first season was like okay the
second season like really took Dallas I
totally agree so it takes a little time
I mean there's just there's a lot
there's a lot of programming we have
like 900 hours with Housewives ok so
like what is like ok so ladies of London
first season yes incredible for the
people that watch it I don't think that
many people watch it but you guys gave
it another chance and then it kind of
took off for a while right what is like
do you guys have shows like I feel like
you never canceled shows after first
season like you always give it a chance
yeah like Dallas like probably like
ratings wives wasn't amazing but you
gave it another chance and those girls
worked it and they knew what they had to
do I think you can learn lessons from
your first season I can I think that it
does take I mean something some things
you just have to cancel princesses of
Long Island we canceled over season what
are they thank you for welcome like as a
success look we just had a boy we was
like as a princess of Long Island like
thank you yeah that was horrifying
that was my choice no like that no
but I believe in everything Bravo like I
stand behind Bravo like I should work
there like I know I was gonna ask you
what you thought of it because I was
like come on it was like you're people
no it was horrifying it was really about
are things like we're not like that like
at all think you guys time the worst of
the worst like in a gutter I'm sorry
well speaking of working at Bravo yeah
fun fact yeah is when I was in college I
interviewed for a internship at Bravo
but like it really wasn't me like wait
what year is this like after I met like
maybe 2000 like 13 or 14 oh my god I was
definitely there yeah for sure but like
it was like the only internship
available and it was in statistics on my
research like now and it's being like
social in content it was the only one
available so obviously it took it and I
met with someone named Jeremy Lee Joon
do you know him I know him very well he
loved and really hit it off like
obviously the internship was not for me
correct um but like just what would my
life have been if I did maybe I would
have been you you you might have been
made well I was already there I'm glad
you're you yeah you would have poisoned
me to get my job Oh completely why do
you think I haven't taken a sip of this
Oh cuz you shouldn't because it's
[ __ ] nasty because we never change
your cups this has been here since
Monday oh I was gonna take a sip too but
now I know now I know now they know give
me your top five housewives in terms of
who I'd like to watch on arrow at people
err only because you have a special like
air only whoever watch um
Nene Kyle Richards Dorinda Sonja who's
gonna be my fifth one rounding it out oh
I'm gonna go with Theresa yeah I'll go
with Trey I'm a Jersey girl I was gonna
say do you feel like I like Melissa to
you a loyalty to the East Coast
housewives because like yes a three out
of five we're like New York New Jersey I
only watch New York New Jersey in
Atlanta like yeah only and then I had to
get into Beverly Hills just so good
properties um everything else I was like
yeah it's nice to see rich people
everyone in Jersey's like houses are
it's always going what do you think of
Ellingham okay so me and Jackie have a
major struggle with her because she came
on the breath and was unbelievably
lovely gorgeous her husband is so hot
and he's so cute they're gorgeous people
we saw her two nights ago at the OK
Magazine party she was like so nice she
remembered us we went out afterwards we
were drinking in the best time we
absolutely loved her in person but I'm
just not a fan of the character she
plays because I think she's incredibly
nice and lovely to everyone in that
doesn't make for great TV and I'm just
like I don't like her on the show but
like I completely sound I've separated
her Teddy on the show and Teddy in real
life they're two different people to me
I am curious to see like if she comes
back like what season two Teddy will be
I think she'll have a moment where
she'll turn it around
I think she's learning like as she goes
like I could see like her injury like
really getting in and Joey Lisa Rinna
and Erica Jane is like the trio that
I've never knew I needed yeah I I'm
actually in love with three but see I
was despising to read them like please
don't bring her back and then you did
and I changed my mind
right I think you really have to like
let [ __ ] but you guys like you
manipulate us like I'm sorry like you do
like i motion terrorism no it is like
I'm like no sorry I don't like to read
up in like you're making me like her
yeah it's it's kind of it when I travel
genius Bravo announced a bunch of shows
that are coming back in summer house was
not a little list it's coming back all
right yeah is everyone coming wait do
you like summer house is that like a big
show of your I love Steven he's like
what am I good friends he's such a
gossip I don't love the show but I watch
it what do you think of like Carl and
like work his twins you don't really
care do you think do you find Carl
attractive no I don't find it anyone on
the show attractive not even Kyle cook
no I don't think it's cute at all he's
really not my type okay our Jackson
Brady engage because they've been like
both wearing wedding rings
they are not engaged as far as I know
it's Carol instead we're getting her own
show not that I know of she said okay
like just what it's like I'm taking no
I'm taking mental notes okay this is
such an important question this is why I
need the toaster it's cause like I have
dementia like I litter don't remember
anything okay
you are literally an 85 year old Barbie
Boca and I actually don't know what
where I am right now
okay Lala love her all right there's
like a lot going on in my mind okay
because this is the thing this last
reunion has been really kind of did you
like it I'm braking unbelievable yeah I
thought it was better than all the whole
season I thought these three episodes of
a union is all I needed because things
have shifted in terms of power.yes and I
think that the show is amazing but I
think it might have an expiration date
because the the hierarchy of Lisa being
their boss like doesn't really work
anymore because they're all becoming
rich successful famous stars right so
why the hell do they need to listen to
Lisa Vanderpump anymore her role is
becoming almost obsolete which is the
matriarch though she's like the mother
figure she's like who Sheena goes to
being like
like I skip through at least of a
different parts like and I saw I know
everything about the show so Lala is now
like on Lisa's level you know she it
like she is like doling out advice like
Martin Scorsese watch his head and from
paroles
Oh at least so we know what it's like to
buy Chanel bad it's like she is and it's
like it's shifting things and she's like
the youngest one right yeah it's so
bizarre
the powerhouse every time they bring up
Brando they're like we all love him
everyone's except for Jeana ever don't
know we love him because she didn't get
him right on the private jet
exactly even though she was going to
Vegas the next day oh yeah so much drama
okay but till we have this theory yeah
that Lala is eventually gonna graduate
if she stays we're like on this linear
track yeah she is almost gonna be like
too good to be I'm better from pearls
and she might be a real housewife of
Beverly Hills if she marries Randall she
has to marry Randall and she's been
wearing a band on her finger just saying
she might marry Randall I mean listen a
home girl can get it she is literally
gorgeous she is literally a walking
sexual stick and I love her huh the moon
and back and you know what I think I
think the first three seasons that she
was on I wasn't as enamored by her
because I think we all had this like
stigma who she was and what she was
doing because people were like sweetie
like you're driving a Range Rover yeah
like she's being so shady about she that
would have a problem and in this season
she [ __ ] owned it and then was so
empowering to women being like these men
yes has to stop and in that sound bite
where she's like I just want to spread
my legs and like and I was like by the
way that's the same thing we're like she
is Gloria Steinem of Bravo yeah
but then when they went to the reunion
and they asked everyone like do you guys
agree with Lala's version of feminism
everyone's like well it's not really
like my version but like why it's the
greatest version yeah I think some
people look at it it's like okay uses
her Dramat right like you're using your
body for I agree so equality for all
listen use what you got I could but
please it looks like I got a mans owed
Manzo's yeah Manzo's any future for them
I don't thinks I don't think so either
I kind of agree okay what is a show that
has been on Bravo that didn't return but
that you like wish we make a comeback
you're not gonna agree with me and
you're gonna think I'm so lame and
you're never around work of art what's
up exactly
this is like way before your time like
2010 2011 it was SJP it was like Project
Runway but with artists it was actually
like really it was very cool to see like
how they could create art because I'm
the opposite of an artist and I
genuinely really enjoyed that job really
I think a lot of people want not nine
but NYC prep to come back okay yeah I
think that was like the big one that
people want to see wherever it was and I
grew up in the city and like I was a
little younger than see like I knew of
them on Facebook and it was like us got
it's so we're that like you pitch
reality show when you get the person
that you need like these were like the
kids who are like cool at the time yes
yes I do I don't want them know it
obviously those people are there tears
yeah they're like my edge now that's a
really good point what about gallery
girls you know like it could have been
as I'm going loved it by the way like I
never got into it because I was like
younger at the time I think if it was on
now I totally would have watched it yeah
it had a great name right I mean gallery
girls was everything and I think if you
brought it back I think would be
successful I think it would be
successful - you need an art show I
think it was a little ahead of its time
yeah I think it was absolutely ahead of
its time and I think if we brought it
back maybe with Lee because New Yorkers
like that's the thing like we're [ __ ]
or is like so a thing there and it's so
head bro which is why I like let's like
go to Basel yeah like like spend that
would be like I love art Baba mother I
just want you to know yeah everyone it's
a Miami it's come back like that's just
what they're saying oh okay so if you
want to take that back no I got it I've
got a list I've got a running list so
the powers that be no I got it I don't
watch it but I'm going to because Ryan
Serhant coming on the show I heard tell
it like Serhant is amazing really people
are like so moved by it have you never
seen it I love him he's like a genuinely
good guy
it's a belt it's like a makeover show
well it's like Tabitha it's like Tabitha
but he is a very funny
it has he makes yeah he can like
convince someone to like he can sell
ketchup popsicle to a woman in white
gloves so he was on a Friday
Fridays and he got moved to Tuesday's is
that like a more prestigious what is
because like biermann's are on on
Fridays Brady that's a weird night
because people like go about people
don't watch TV on Friday nights I mean I
record it so like I watch it anyway yeah
I think we try to build on our schedule
so what is KY mean right spread out yeah
correct I mean our biggest nights or
Sunday nights Oh Mondays yeah because it
Lana's on somebody like that kicks off
the week like watch happens I have our
biggest night as always
this Monday's really Sunday Monday
Tuesday's like really like build up our
week people want to know how they get
tickets watch outside because I don't
know how to tell them because like I
just abused my power god damn I mean
yeah like tweet her and then she'll
tweet the powers-that-be it's honestly
we don't have a great system for it huh
a lot of times it's just tweeting Andy I
donate to every single charity that
asked me every single one
you know people Instagram me I try and
hook them up the best I can but it's
only 30 people in the audience like
you've seen the studio it's legitimately
half this size so the first time I went
to watch happens live it was in the old
studio but yeah Barrymore one on one and
they did the the drag queens where they
all dressed up as different versions of
her and one of them was josie grossy
yeah which was just like I think what I
love about watch dramas live and what
everyone loves about watch out inside
it's like it hits the points that it
needs to hit yeah I feel like a lot of
times when you interview like
celebrities or like notable people
they're like they circle the drain I'm
like the things we really want to talk
about like I don't really need to hear
about santa clarita diet like i want to
talk about josie grossy of course and
and like yeah because like nobody please
into that and you'll be like how big is
your dick right right and you're like I
kind of want to know how big Shaq's dick
just like trouble all the time
who's daddy's boss is that guy Michael
uh it is Michael who had sunbeh cero but
it's also Francis as our president of
Bravo okay so he has he's overlords yeah
but is he in trouble
yeah he gets in trouble I don't think he
gets in trouble by like Michael at the
necessary production company but
certainly he doesn't mean he knows the
workings of Bravo so he's not really in
trouble in that way I think he's more in
trouble like socially with other
celebrities because he'll be like no we
don't want to associate because they'll
talk about his fourth diary is it was he
reading a fourth diary not yet it's a
little too soon okay like he needs daddy
needs a break as he would like to say
daddy that's it Sam I'm like I'm not
calling you daddy
oh so let's just go you will I bet let's
dispel that rights a lesbian I can't in
good conscience I got to forever but
we're ready three minutes over oh my god
like you have to come back because I so
so many more questions time and I think
maybe we should you just like a podcast
only episode with Darrin like you've
never seen her before
yeah maybe done for that like exposed
but I want the stack of blue cards and
me well it's podcast always so no one
would see it whatever I just know the
visuals guys and we're by the way I had
one more question for you yes and this
was my first question I forgot to ask
for it you like never post on Instagram
and I just think like you have such a
like you have the privilege of like
being in a really cool job and like
definitely things people would want to
see yeah and like you don't really give
people no fans like a reason to follow
you because like
like the one I went your Instagram I saw
like three post down was from the
morning breath I was like a hundred
years ago yeah you know I mean yeah so I
feel like if someone else was in your
position they would be like a thirst
monster like out here Hawking for
Instagram correct and they want to know
why it is that you don't do that because
I would I think the job that I'm in I
want to maintain I mean I think it gives
me a level of professionalism I think
that's one of the reasons Andy hired me
because he knew that I was gonna freak
out every single time Ramona Singer was
around right I also like to create a
little bit of an illusion like my job is
very cool I love it absolutely but at
the same time I don't want to show
everyone every single second cuz that's
not special to me anymore
so I curate my Instagram as best that
they can I probably could do better I
could learn some things from you maybe
okay give me some tutorials I'll talk
about it maybe I should take an
Instagram here and then I'll pose no we
will and then I'll post it we're gonna
be like please follow me because I'm
desperate I'll make sure guys everyone
follow down your car page Aaron yes
actor good name thank you it's actually
my name just backwards
is there any at the end there's an e as
my middle and harp so my name is Darrin
almost I the car I thought I was
spelling it wrong this whole time no
you're right like a fish or to complain
yeah I get it I guess yeah yeah okay
well you should really be out there like
hawk and print certain powers and we'll
help you the toasters are insanely
influential so like no the toaster I
mean what do you think I came on the
show you know what I mean like this is
me Hawking so everyone follow carpet
Aaron on ACR mcar PDA are bye and thank
you guys so much for tuning in I happy
an amazing weekend you get super drunk
we are the morning toast we're live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on Facebook's make sure you like us
or on YouTube make sure you subscribe to
us and then we're also available on the
podcast app a little later on in the day
so make sure you subscribe there I'm
super tired I can't wait to get back in
bed I'll see you on Monday